字幕志愿者 李宗盛
欢迎收看理财达人秀的筹码教学单元
歌有筹必报
今天歌之错能改
怎么说呢
歌叫全证小歌
他有在教全证吗
他一直在教大家看各种筹码
全证我们之前有教
其实有一集非常入门基本的
那今天呢
歌从操就业
为什么
因為最近很多人都喊我沒有錢
不是我知道你還有錢
是我知道你沒有錢了
所以如何用小錢來賭波動呢
現在進入到第四季
結果壞消息反而越來越多
反而都希望第四季來個大反彈
很多公司開法說會不會有好消息
現在告訴你
恐怕好消息是越來越少
但是波動越大
對權政就越有利
這邊先做風險提醒
權政是會吃龜鈴膏的
所以不要拿大錢出來玩
先學會再拿小錢試試看
把自己的風險降到最低好不好
小哥你是六師弟回來了
六師弟
因為之前我們這一堂課
大部分都是交籌碼
但是你是權政小哥對不對
我們之前有講一集比較簡單的
而且你本人就是靠權政起家的啊
什麼靠權政什麼書一本書啊
還得到什麼權王啊
對很多獎
豐功偉業
但是後來因為聽說發行商越來越驚
全證不好賺
沒錯 因為主要就是城市交易
對嘛 那你今天為什麼要交全證呢
我們散戶賺不到全證的錢啊
因為我知道你沒有錢
哈哈哈哈
我知道有些人那個錢輸一輸
跟我當年一樣
我當年為什麼會玩全證呢
身上只剩幾百塊
對 好慘
因為買股票呢
因為大概也只能買零股了
那想說至少這個全證看起來
還可以買個幾十張啊
突然有大戶的感覺
對 買股票一張都按不下去了
那只好來玩權證
後來發現買權證
你真的要挑時間喔
怎麼說 現在是好時間嗎
現在是非常好的時間
怎麼說 我覺得現在景氣壞到不行
景氣壞到你可以買認售啊
多空都可以做
對 因為最近的波動都變大了
最近波動那天台積電都這麼活潑
你看我們錄影的當天
他向上從來沒那麼活潑過
向下倒數活潑過幾次
對啊
他們那麼活潑
你也可以用這個認授權再來參與
那這個最近又到一個活潑的季節了
怎麼說
各位你要記得
這個活潑的季節就是1470月
很好記嘛
假如你有打麻將的話很好記
聽1471 147桶
那1470月又這種
因為1470月的法說
特別有波動一點
因為1.470月的法書會
他有時候會剛好跟著季報一起公布
跟著季報一起公布
緊張刺激
就很刺激
而且要講下一季展望
緊張刺激
最重要就是在下一季展望
只要下一季展望不好
那外資隔天就鐵了心的在砍
就向下波動
向下波動
反正只要有波動
我們完全就很喜歡
所以我們先來看一下
這個錄影後的法說會
有什麼
10月25號
有2337的望虹
3035的智原
對 10月26號有友達
友達剪之後掛牌
28號風新鋼鐵股
這比較無聊吧
對 他真的是比較無聊
他的法說會隔天有稍微比較大一點的波動
但還是很無聊
這次是496普瑞
這個可刺激
這隔天不是漲停就跌停
很刺激
還有這個11月9日的
這也變得很刺激
這也很刺激
所以說這種法書位的隔天
法書位當天你就要買了
因為他隔天都很刺激
看好就買認購
看差你就買認售
我怎麼知道我要看好還是看壞
你假如什麼都不知道的
那認購跟認售一起買
為什麼?這樣不就抵銷了嗎?
沒有抵銷喔
因為你只要全證挑的好的話
認購跟認售一起買
只要隔天漲跌停你都會賺錢
要賭它漲跌停
對 要漲跌停喔
假如隔天平盤都會賠錢喔
好 沒關係
我覺得這裡面如果是電子股的
可能壞消息會比好消息多一點
可是如果說是像面板那種
已經壞消息一整年的
也許不見得
原物料就要留意囉
最近又在打仗囉
原物料可能不見得會是那麼多的壞消息
簡單分類一下好不好
不錯
各位你就按照這個簡單分類來玩
好
那我們來看一下
首先來看一下這個3035的智源
這檔真的是紅了兩年
現在往下有它的份
這個智源法書會
法書會我們最重要最重要的
我們是要看一天後
一天後不是當天啊
不是 因為法書會是下午開
所以要隔天
對 下午開 開完之後
隔天有驚喜啦
我們來看看這個一天後
它上漲機率只有3 4%
對
也就是說常常法書會
講的是壞消息比較多
那我們再看這更刺激的
這一天後在今年7月26號
各位還記得1 4 7 10月嗎
對
所以7月26日的隔天跌8%
好 那個時候有點像是
本來大家對智元的預期非常高
我覺得大家也要列入考慮
不是只看它7月的
當它第一月、四月講得極好
那7月如果沒那麼好
也是一個殺傷力
對 沒錯
好 來看一下這4月份
4月份講比較好嗎
講得好
它上半年講得好
對 隔天漲4.1%
那再看一下去年的10月份
也是講得好
去年10月份 隔天漲停
再隔天再漲停
講太好了吧
哇 講太好了
很刺激的喔
所以今年的隔天
可能就很刺激喔
那種很刺激的喔
你千萬不要買股票去賭
因為你買股票去賭呢
不是漲不是賺10%
就是賠10%嘛
那個是不大對等的
不對等
但是你用全戰來賭
那個漲停跟跌停的賺賠是不對等的
那我們再來看
等於小哥今天挑的就是波動大的
容易在開玩法說會後有大戲劇性抓馬表現
對 我們最喜歡
完全最喜歡大波
大波就在把所有的隔天玩
小哥喜歡戲劇性人格
我們看一下這2409友達
法蘇惠隔天上漲機率4-3%
稍微好一點
那只要上漲平均漲2.1%
只要下跌平均跌2.8%
波動也稍微大了一點
那我們來看一下在今年
今年友達的時間跟
1470月
1470月是這樣子
友達不一定是在4月份隔天
不一定在4月份比較刺激它這個是在5月份比較刺激5月18號隔天跌4.5%這個5月17號這兩天法說
他可能有參加論壇
參加論壇
那這4月26號隔天跌4.1%
在去年的4月29號
這也是1.17月
講了啥
隔天跌停
再隔天跌8.2%
不過那時候就是面板的高點
對 這個很刺激
連續兩天跌了十幾%
所以這種你假如用全鎮參與的話
也蠻不錯的
買到認壽賺翻
接下來我們看
2337的旺宏
這個法說有參考性嗎
他們法說只會講樂觀
隔天也不錯
旺宏上漲紀律有40%
只要漲就漲2.4%
所以相對來看也是波動比較大一點
只要跌3.3%
相對來看也是波動大了一點
那在今年的7月26日
隔天漲4%
1月25日隔天漲6%
都一直講好事
這個也是波動大的
厲害
不過就那麼一天
隔天又恢復了
所以法所有的隔天特別好玩
拭目以待
因為現在看起來記憶體的景氣並不理想
但是也有據說
有某些公司會號稱他有低價庫存
然後會說最低點已經過去了
並不是指他是另外他的同業
但是這家那麼會說
相信會說出一朵花來
好不好
試試看
聽聽看
但是也要留意
一直很樂觀的他
如果講得不好
那就很可怕
因為他一直很樂觀
大家會失望
對 會嚇到
我還以為你會講多好
原來講也不過這樣
就不能容忍你不樂觀了
所以我們說
全證 你就要找適合投資的時機
你千萬不要
聽說這檔股票很好
結果它沒再動你就跑去買
你得到消息太早的話 那完蛋了
要等它開始搖
開始搖
開始動的時候才能進去
那這全證適合投資的時機
最適合的就法說會
因為法說會波動就很大
一般人要得到正確資訊
也常常只能在法說會
好 那第二個地板股
殺的很低了
最近很多股票變地板股了喔
這句話怎麼今年常常聽你講
空投年
空投年下殺出量波動大
那就適合來玩全鎮地板股
搶了就要跑喔
那第三個除全息
但這個要多投年喔
今年是空投年 今年除全息特難玩
今年貼息的比較多
貼血很多 而且常常都是除全球開始跌
對
所以除全球一定要多頭的食肉丸
好 所以我們來教各位
可能今年就賭前兩個了
對 教各位怎麼來挑全證
好 一樣跟可轉載一樣
好 我們有五個口訣
不過可轉載我們濃縮成一個字
這全證沒辦法濃縮成一個字
我們只能用這個五個字
因為如果你濃縮成一個字就是
波波小夠優
不過至少我跟你講
我至少我還找押韻
波波小夠優
好像也是個
也可以啦
好像也是五個字
第一個
標的要大波
標的的波動要夠大
小波自動刪掉
不要
中華電信不要
中鋼太牛不要
你要這個標的要政府很大的
要大波的
那第二個
權政它有肇事喔
那肇事我們就要它的隱含波動率
隱含波動率我們就要穩定的
那小一點的
反而隱含波動率要小而穩定
對 適合取回家
對 就適合取回家
所以標的假如大波
權政又小而穩定的
那就是非常好的啦
你內外各一個就對了
對 內外各
所以全證小穩波
全證肇事呢 也不一定要小
然後又穩定
好 第三呢 買賣價差要小
我之前有看過真的
我買了之後要賣出那個價差超大的
你說買的時候是小 賣的時候變大
買的時候就可能沒注意
所以這真的要注意
當你要賣的時候就發現
對 不是那麼好賣
常常我買的時候它很小
我要賣的時候它就變大了
因為我一次買太多了
它就不敢讓我買了
不敢讓你買了
所以它的買賣價差就變大了
買賣價差變大
其實只要微買的隱含波動率穩定
那你就不要怪它了
它只是不想賣給你而已
還有這回事啊
對 這種我常遇到
小哥大戶常遇到
因為我挑的權證都挑很好
然後他發現
我怎麼把這麼好的權證賣給你
內行人來了 還買很多少貨
還一次買那麼多
所以他就怎麼樣
他就把價差給拉大
好 那第四呢
唯買量要足夠喔
你的意思是這樣才賣得掉嗎
對
所以通常唯買量足夠的權證
就代表他造勢的不錯
那有的人講
那唯賣量呢
常常你看到尾賣量只剩10張的
他都是好權陣喔
因為他習壽了
捨不得賣給你
好 那第五呢
槓桿大最優
所以最後還是要大槓桿
要大的
要大小的
大隻的
就是前面是挑的條件
後面是
槓桿大最優
聽起來不錯
我為了押韻
後面只要打最優了
不然他會打什麼呢
這哪邊有押韻
我們五口訣
標的要大波 權證小穩波
買賣價差小 回買量足夠
槓桿大最優
押O運就對了
對 押O運的好不好
做節目都要繳盡腦汁的
不愧當過老師的人
對啊 因為你這樣子記起來
你就會挑權證了
槓桿也要挑大的喔
完全就是以小博大 你不要挑小的
挑小的變以大博小
好
那我們來總結
這幾個字很多人
小哥你說五口訣就搞一搞25個字
太累
上次其實也有講到
多字不見得難
三個字X槓比特難好不好
之前教過
誰還記得起來
X槓比
我已經把25個字濃縮變三個字了
就三個字了
對啊 所以記得假
好 插槓比越小越好
好 那我們再看一下
什麼叫插槓比
講插槓比之前
我們要先知道價差比
你看 知道插槓比之前
你還要價差比
是要差幾次
沒辦法啦
這個價差比我們可以這樣講
就是你買賣所賠的錢
你一買一賣你都會賠掉錢
為什麼
為什麼 因為買價跟賣價
一定是買價比較低啊
賣價比較低 賣價比較高
假如當下你要買 你只買1塊錢
當下你要賣 你只賣0.99
所以買賣一定會有價差買賣有價差所以鑽石不要隨便買鑽石的價差比有的50% 有的70%喔商人的騙對不對所以鑽石很久也一顆永流傳啦
什麼意思 賣不掉的意思啊
賣賣賣不掉
太好了 所以你老公買給你的時候
就賣不掉 你就可以永遠保存他
快去叫你老公買一顆
買了之後你就不想變賣他
因為他的微買價跟微賣價差很多
所以我們全證的尾賣價跟尾賣價不能差很多
所以像這種尾賣0.99尾賣1
這就是不錯的全證
等於他們的差距很小很小
對 因為你這買
你買1萬
賣9,900
你就賠了1%而已
可以接受的
價差比就是1%
那假如遇到槓桿是5倍
那差槓比就把1%再除以5
變成0.2%
好 但是越小越好
等於它的槓桿到底要越大越好
價差越小越小越好
槓桿越大越好
這樣子算起來的差槓比才會變得更小
對 只要差槓比在0.3%以下都是不錯的權證
因為我們的交易稅就是0.3%
這樣記最簡單
那這差槓比是0.2%代表說
你的股票漲0.2%
你的權證就準備賺錢
那一般我們買股票
股票一定要涨0.3%以上才会赚钱
因为要扣掉税
对 因为要扣掉税
还要手续费
所以差钢比我们就这样子
只要差钢比越小越好
好
那我们来看一下
会忘记的就截图回去反复看
对啊 会忘记就暂停
暂停来看
来 这个权证我们就要跟各位讲
什么叫佛的权证
什么叫坑人的权证
好 现在哪一种多
现在哪一种多
波动大的时候
坑人的权证会变多
所以接下来可能坑人的权证
我们要会分辨
反正只要价差很大
那就是坑人的
那佛的权证
它的隐含波动率
隐含波动率它就会比较低
而且稳定
小稳坡
没错
照我记起来
那坑人的权证就是高
大又不稳定
高乱坡
對 那否則全陣呢 槓桿會比較大
好 大隻
大隻的
客人的全陣槓桿就很小
小隻
太迷你了
那價差比呢
剛剛講要很小
對 否則全陣比較小
那客人全陣就會比較大一點
好 那我們來舉例一下
因為望宏要法說會啦
所以我特地挑一檔望宏的全陣
到錄影的這一刻是好全陣
到錄影的時候 是
然後各位你到錄影的時候
你看這場全震的報價應該就不一樣了
槓桿有可能會變大
好 可能會變大
好 那這場全震呢
075197元大的全震
真心覺得元大全震還不錯啦
好 給他一個讚 跟各家比起來的話
他的這個全震的微買的波動力
看起來是比較穩定一點
因為元大畢竟市占高嘛
所以他有時候在一些手續費啦
退佣上面會讓你覺得
這條件沒有很好 對
可是發行商品上我覺得相對蠻嚴謹的
因為它的倍是大
它可以賺到很多過業費
所以它造勢品質相對比較好一點
這沒有業配喔
對
特別講一下
小哥你是不是收到元大錢
真的沒有
沒有業配
不然我就不會說它退優跟手續費XXX了
真的沒有
好
那我們來看一下
這個它的造勢波動率53
只要敢寫出來的有種
為什麼 因為他總不能我截圖53
各位你看到節目的時候剩下50
那你就可以
小哥截圖的時候53
你現在肇事波動也要53
你可以調高
調高代表說我們要把這東西
因為波動變大了
我要賣貴一點
可以啊 那你至少
對之前買的人來講
他比較好啊
我之前是地攤買的
你現在變成那個
這個專櫃裡面的價格還不錯
所以這個只要微買波動率敢寫出來
就不錯
好 這也是一個指標
好 那第二呢我們看到實質槓桿
實質槓桿有10倍
10倍全正算很好的喔
剛剛你不是舉例5倍
這更大隻啊
所以要更大 比5倍大都算好
我每次看到10倍的我就流口水
只要10倍的
10倍這個價差呢
各位看一下這價差0.01
這加差0.1
也很小很小
這個報價已經報得很緊了
各位你看買張是499
賣張掛10張
洗手 你剛剛有提到
捨不得賣那麼好的
各位 他說小哥10張我要怎麼買
你就買10張
過了幾秒鐘或幾分鐘
他又會再撲出來
你就繼續買
要慢慢收
對 這種全證我都一次買個幾百張
反正慢慢收慢慢收
還不錯
沒有業配喔 舉例而已
真的沒業配好不好
好 原大下一位記得告訴我
原大要業配可以來找我
這是真的沒業配
剛剛講到不對等的漲跌停
一般人可能無法議會
不對等我們特別拿這檔給各位看
這檔是剛剛那檔10倍槓桿的
它的隱藍波動率是53%
各位看一下隱藍波動率在下降的過程中
全震價格也會往下降
所以隱含波動率很重要
你要穩定
不能我買了你是53
我明天要賣你剩51
那這樣子對我來講就不公平
所以穩定的隱含波動率
這是我們買全震最重要的
好 那第二我們來看一下
這檔全震當標的漲停的時候
全震會從0.49漲到1.19漲了多少
0.7
漲滿多的喔
那跌停會不會賠0.7呢
很老可憐
賠0.7就0啦
才0.49怎麼
就負負的了
不可能變負的嘛
所以跌停還有0.15喔
那這什麼意思
趙華假設你賭這個他的法說
你賭兩次
賭兩次
就是這一季賭一次
下一季再賭一次嘛
那賭兩次
一次讓你賭到漲停
一次讓你賭到跌停
我賺錢
買股票剛好沒來
對不對 我買100塊 漲停110
跌停90嘛
沒來 對不對
買權證沒有喔
買權證是漲停賺0.7喔
跌停賠0.34
那我就當然往漲的方向買啊
就是你買了
因為你不曉得明天會漲還跌
但是明天有可能
這一次漲停 下一次跌停
對不對 可能一半一半
但是你買全正呢
漲停的時候賺0.7
跌停的時候賠0.3
如果我買認售也會這樣嗎
也會這樣
你只要挑的好就好
所以你假如認購跟認售都買
恭喜你啊
漲跌停你就會賺錢
你只要比例要挑對喔
比例要挑對
就兩邊買的槓桿成金額要一樣
那如果他沒那麼金
是不是還是以認購為優先呢
現在這個歲月
現在這個有點...所以還是要搞懂法說會後比較有可能的行情走向對不對例如說我們都已經知道最近半導體有非常多的風風雨開訪說可能沒有好消息
那就要往可能是瘦的方向走
假如沒有把握沒關係 兩個都買
反正就賭它明天有大波動
但是記得一定要挑十倍槓桿的
你不要挑那個0.2倍一倍的
那就不會動囉
那就不會動
所以我們就要特別來跟各位講
你千萬不要買到爛的權證
我們來找
我在幾萬檔權證裡面挑出來的
大家自己去找是誰發的
我們這邊就不得罪人
沒有發
我們沒有把發行商的名字寫上去
但是查查也是有
查查我也不是在陰他
因為他的槓桿就太低了
這種槓桿就不會動
我們要大波
他沒有波
對啊 全鎮槓桿
認購槓桿小於2
比融資還不如
叫什麼全鎮 比融資還爛
可是全鎮利息是超高的
全鎮的時間價值是流失非常快的
就你槓桿那麼小
小於2的我都覺得都很爛
所以這幾檔
它的有效槓桿都低於2
都很爛
爛全鎮
所以這種全鎮都不要碰
低於2的不要碰
你乾脆去買 乾脆融資好了
融資都比他波動賺得多
融資都比他好
好 那第二個呢
認售槓桿小於1的
最很多喔
是 認售
對 這變成一大博小的權政
來看一下這認售槓桿有多爛的
給各位看 很恐怖
付的是怎麼回事
因為他是認售
因為認售
認售所以是付的
你看這邊有一坨拉鍋
大部分都是合一跟中天
等於是小於負一對不對
對
大於負一
可是我們大部分都講絕對值
好 講絕對值
你想小於大於
觀眾想去看國中數學了
負越多越好
這個負越大越好
對 負十最好
好 負十最好
越負越好
這負0.2這什麼鬼
這個的槓桿就太小了
各位看
槓桿0.2代表什麼意思呢
代表投資人花1萬
發行商拿2000去避險
8000塊幹嘛
8000塊留著自己花你知道嗎
然後呢又收你一堆時間價值
對
那不如自己去空股票算了
你還買全證幹嘛
槓桿小真的是致命的缺點
對
你下次再發這種槓桿低於1的
這個我們勸發行商回去把那個
全證書改一改
不要再說它以小博大了
因為這種全證就是以大博小
不要發這種奈米桿的好不好
對 奈米
奈米桿
買了都沒感覺
都沒有feel
來看一下這種全證
買了都沒feel
你有沒有買進來你都不知道
對 放進去一下下都沒感覺
這一買了都沒感覺
那我們來看這種全證槓桿-0.2
太少了
太迷你了
那也迷
各位看一下
他的報價價差又很大
這個報價價差大
也是致命商剛剛講的報價價差
越小越好
越緊越好
這個價差大本人有一點點功勞
唉唷 為什麼
這是有故事
原本他報價報很緊
對
被你弄鬆了
我就打電話跟他講
是打電話
不是行為把他弄鬆
打電話跟他講說
你們這槓桿那麼小
報價又那麼緊
你一定會讓投資人不小心買到
買到了發現怎麼樣
我怎麼買這場權證
股票跌2%也不動
跌3%也不動
跌4%好不容易動了
我只不過是外盤變內盤
就也沒賺
他一聽說
小哥你講的蠻有道理的
我們以後盡量避免
不要發行這種權證
這次我把它報價拉大
讓投資人不要買到
還有這樣子 讓投資人不要買到
因為投資人看到這個投資人也不想買
至少比較不會買到
因為報價報恩緊的一般投資人都會想買
因為它的槓桿真的太小了
槓桿這麼小最重要的原因就是因為
它的隱含波動率太大了
剛剛講要小穩波
它這個變成大亂波了
對 它隱含波動率到330
這個標的的波動率也才560
560你這個造勢造到330
你買到賠錢的機率就很大
這樣會不會是比較小的券商
造勢能力不足的問題呢
它是比較小型的券商
最近它都發這種
很大隱含波動率的權證
我覺得你發這麼大隱含波動率權證
然後他的隱含波動率又不穩定
那這個會投資人買到受傷機率比較高
那各位我們來看一下他的情境分析
買這種權證1.47
標的跌停的時候才變1.51
1.47標的跌停變1.51
也就是說跌停你賺不到3%
跌停賺不到3%
通常我們買認售
假如槓桿5倍的話
跌停我至少賺50%
這個是跌停你賺不到3%
那我就去買線股還比較好
空線股比較划算
你認售全證不能賣太便宜
我說不能賣太便宜
你也不要賣貴成這樣
賣到300多
你叫投資人怎麼玩
因為你隱含撥動力到300多
全證就變貴
全證變貴槓桿就變小
太小了
太小了投資人買了
他就不會動了
買不會動
因為槓桿太小
槓桿太小那個
全證跟死魚一樣
好
對啊
那就比較威脅你了
好 所以全證也有口訣
你的標的要大波
但是你隱含的波動率要小波
再加著要小波
在外面要大波的意思
然後呢
你的槓桿要超過5倍以上
最好有10倍喔
所以槓桿要大隻
所以小哥每次舉的比喻
都讓人家覺得非常好記喔
那當然你會說
如果只看法術會
我不是只玩一天
我沒有想玩一天
我想天天玩怎麼辦
好 所以在榮耀班裡面
會來告訴你喔
有人的權證
很可以天天玩
而且他有好的權證
讓你天天玩喔
不要玩上癮喔
記得權證就是以小博大
不要拼身家喔
好 今天非常謝謝小哥
又幫我們上了一堂權證課
而且還幫我們列了口訣
好學習啊
那這邊正好還是要提醒大家
因為最近大家可能在股票市場
多多少少有點受傷或是壓力比較大
所以買現股花的錢多
也不要讓自己造成的風險太高的話
可以考慮了解一下全鎮這樣的商品
可是因為全鎮有時間價值
千萬不要把它當成股
放著不管一定會虧零
今天小哥教得非常實用
希望大家回去細細的學
細細的想學好才進場好不好
好 那今天的歌有抽V爆就到這邊了
我们下次再会了
拜拜